il y a quelques mois en arrière
aurait-il osé un tel geste aujourd'hui
ils disent ne faire qu'un tous unis
autour d'une cabane bouillon de colère
malgré le froid mordant
[Musique]
cherche à nous enfumer l'histoire du
smic qui a été augmentée c'est pas vrai
c'est la prime d'activités qu'ils ont
saucissonné l'année nous on est des
retraités on les enganes moi qui a dix
ans outre et ça normal on n'a pas des
déclarations sur les retraites rien du
tout ou très ça normal puis le lit sf
puis le cac 40 déjà les boîtes de 4,46
paient elles payent c'est le ps qu'elle
doive et ben ont cependant la panade on
est le fric il est toujours eu de plus
en plus de peau les pauses route de plus
en plus pauvres et les riches ont plus
de plus en plus riches
le campement était à bille sur un
terrain privé
juste à côté d'une sortie d'autoroute
irréprochable indélogeable les gilet
jaune passent leurs journées ici la
cabane visible de loin est devenue une
tribune politique à ciel ouvert pour moi
c'est gratuit ça me coûte rien là je
suis dans mon élément là ça peut jurer
un dut là il parle de grand débat là il
fait à côté de la plaque
c'est pouvoir d'achat c'est urgent déjà
poire d'achat pour les gens d'en bas là
comme j'ai entendu
j'essaie vraiment ils sont dégueulasses
qu on mérite le respect jean claude est
un des gardiens du temps les
constructions bernard les collègues et
rigole lui rappeler collègues maintenant
c'est lui qui a suggéré l'installation
de toilettes attentif au confort de tous
et de toutes
elle a alors la regarder un peu
alors on se disait personne ne va oser y
aller mais on a appris que ça marche
la vie autour du camp est rythmée par
les arrivées de bois le vrai carburant
des gilet jaune autour du feu une petite
société s'est créé chacun décortique les
propos du président de la république et
imagine une autre société
dans l'est entre guillemets mais il ya
des français dans les riches et aussi
qu'ils déconnent ce que tout ce qui est
admis crise qu on n'a pas entendu parler
encore de la chasse à l'évasion fois là
il n'y a pas encore de résultats alors
ça c'est très bien voir les chiffres et
la tribu s'ils veulent des méthodes pour
la faire la chasse à l'évasion fiscale
on peut leur donner j'étais licencié moi
tu auras j'étais reconnu invalide
je n'ai pas de revanche mais je n'ai pas
droit au rsa
j'ai droit à rien j'ai ma petite pension
d'invalidité pour les droits ça c'est
déjà pas mal
c'est combien 550 euros
bon bah loin avec ça
retour chez des parents encore une
saison ce dernier
temps quatre ans et trois mois
eh bien j'ai un signe et on 38e contrats
cdd
voilà
et ça paie pas les noms parce que je
peux pas avoir de projet je peux pas je
sais pas où je vais je sais pas où je
vais sait jamais combien de temps ça va
tenir on vous lâche du jour au lendemain
vous savez pas où vous allez vous pouvez
pas avoir de projet ça peut pas aller
une france cas pas de projets il faut
avoir une ligne
alors oui le président nous dit qu'il a
son cap
on n'a pas forcément le même cap
au début du mouvement les gilet jaune
occupait le ps voisins jusqu'à ce qu'ils
soient délogés par les gendarmes nous
l'avait dit dégager l'autoroute
et puis junior matin les objectifs la
plus jeune je vais t'expliquer ce que
l'autoroute à baume-les-dames autoroute
c'est nos impôts
dis-moi jan cibula tous mes collègues et
un petit bout l'état l'a vendu au fonds
impatience très bien chez moi j'appelle
ça une spoliation l'autoroute nous
appartient c'est pas au kangourou
elle a été vendue à notre insu mois est
mort est à 8 heures et mon flash à 95
personnes aussi pour m'arrêter pour ça
d'aller 170 autoroute pas l'abs en son
nom mais j'aurais tué quelqu'un ça va
prêter pis les assiettes
s'il vous plaît
tous les week-ends les gilets jaunes
font à manger pour 50 personnes autour
de la table d'une majorité de retraités
certains participent pour la première
fois un mouvement social jamais été
invité c'est la première manifestation
que je fais il ya 128 ans la première
manifestation
on a presque rejoint n'est pas ce qu'on
retrouve des copains qu'on n'a pas fait
pour ça ce mouvement a entraîné entre
nous une solidarité
on est content de se retrouver ensemble
on ne partage pas forcément tous les
mêmes idées mais on est tous réunis pour
la même cause à l'intérieur de la cabane
un homme discret veille au grain dans ce
mouvement sans chef
il ya quand même un intendant cuisinier
trésorier un ancien bûcheron qui
comptent les jours noël en ong pays si
la famille quel support
[Applaudissements]
ça fait surtout là
comme ça oui je n'arrive à rien à tenter
un an après ce que m on aura fait qu'il
ya une sympathie avec leur envers les
quatre personnes voilà les révoltés du
rond-point doute parfois mais le
campement est toujours là et s'approche
d'un troisième mois d'occupation
rien d'étrange